here's a good one how do you encourage
your students to feel
empowered respectful and confident
in the classroom with their peers that's
from emma
wow thanks emma that's a wonderful
question i think that
probably the first thing that comes to
mind is to give them the opportunity to
uh and it's going to sound strange but i
often think about school as
an environment which uh sometimes in
order to try and maintain a positive and
a safe learning environment
we put all these um why's uh fences and
constraints
on our students and i think that
sometimes
almost all the time even though
sometimes
students will do things that you kind of
shake your head out and you think wow
was i ever that silly and naive and
immature and the answer was
yes we all were but i often think you
know we don't give our students enough
credit for what they're capable of doing
i think about some of the students at my
school and the incredible acts of
um selflessness and of thinking other
communities around them
um of you know ingenuity in trying to
serve the people and the needs they see
around them in their families and their
friends with strangers
i think about recently some of the work
that our students did raising funds for
homeless people all around sydney and i
think you know what we need to do
is to open their eyes to the needs
around them and then
give them the capacity let them go help
them see
they have the opportunity and the power
to make that impact rather than saying
no
no this is not for you big people will
solve these problems so i think enabling
them and
helping them see where the big problems
are so that they can address them
that's probably the key thank you
now jerry is asking what's your favorite
subject in maths
oh jerry that's pretty tough that's like
which is your favorite child right
um i think i think i have an answer to
this which i always come back to
um it's a bit like you know different
times i feel like different things and i
enjoy different things
strongly influenced by what i happen to
be teaching at the present time
but if i had to come back to one thing
it's always going to be
geometry i know that sounds a bit
strange it's like oh
shapes that sounds a bit boring but the
reason why i love geometry so much is
that
so many people can say i'm not really
into maths i don't enjoy it i didn't
understand it
but then if you put them in front of
a beautiful piece of art
they can't help but have a visceral
aesthetic experience saying there is
beauty here
to admire and marvel at there was skill
that went into the perfect proportioning
and symmetry of this artwork that i
can't help
but enjoy it and geometry is the
heartbeat underneath that
even if you can't articulate it you're
still experiencing it
and you know that that sense of
mathematics being underneath
everything that we experience around us
that we think is beautiful
i made this reference to music and my
kids before um
someone said once that music is the joy
that we feel
when we're counting but don't know it i
think that geometry is the perfect
example something that's always hiding
beneath the surface
but that everyone can appreciate and
that's why i love it so much
that's a fantastic answer eddie thank
you we're nearly out of time
there's a couple of questions i didn't
get to and i do apologize about that but
i really wanted to finish
on this note eddie if you were to give
us
three takeaways on kindness
suggestions inspirational quotes books
give us three takeaways before we bring
this wonderful conversation to a close
jane i will do my best and i want to say
thank you as well to everyone
who asked questions they were delightful
um i guess where would i start
um okay number one to encourage uh
everyone who's here watching listening i
think i'd say first people
people care um i know that seems like a
bit of a truism
but for me maybe a story i could tell
would really help us understand
the um help me communicate and convey
the importance of this
um i mentioned before that in the last
years of high school for me my mum was
quite sick
but one of the things she was very um
emphatic about
was that she did not want anyone who
didn't have to know
she didn't want them to be aware of what
she was going through and i think she
she didn't want pity unless she was
quite a private person as well
and so as a consequence none of my
friends had any idea what was going on
they didn't know why often i would fall
asleep
in class it was because i was up all
night the previous evening
you know changing my mom's oxygen tank
or something like that um they didn't
know why
sometimes i'd be at school in the
morning and then after
lunch i'd just disappear because when
she was in
palliative care um there were a few
really touch-and-go moments where
you know my brother and sister and i
we're all basically told drop everything
this could be it you want to be there if
this is the last moment that you have
my friends didn't know any of that and
so for the vast majority of them the
first
any of them knew that this happened was
when
uh they found out about the funeral and
were told that they could come
and i still remember the experience of
standing there
surrounded by my friends friends who had
actually progressively been
sort of you know becoming more and more
remote from because
i i couldn't share so much of my life to
them because it was what my family
wanted um but to know that they were
there in that moment supporting me
they cared so deeply about something
that i thought they would say oh we
don't have time for that
people care much more often than we
realize so that's the first thing i hope
encourages people
the second thing is maybe to think about
the simple things that we often get
distracted from in the busyness of life
we're coming to the end of school
holidays at the moment
and all my friends who are not teachers
they always love to joke about school
holidays
uh just so anyone knows i've just been
recently
working on the year 12 major works in
mathematics that my class has put
together and reading
all these essays and watching videos
they've created a lot of fun
but also hard work the thing that i
think about
at those times and everyone's got their
version of this is that when we're busy
we
often get so distracted from the simple
things that bring joy
to us and so i've had a few moments
recently where
you know the weather has had some
beautiful times and in lockdown it's
been all the more important to
get out with the kids i'm very fortunate
i live in a part of sydney where there
is abundant bush land that has been well
protected
and it's just gorgeous to go there and
enjoy
the science and the sounds and the
smells of nature so i think we'll need
to slow down a little bit
and remember those simple things um you
asked for three things so the third
and last one is uh thinking about
possibilities
and what i mean by that is i mean you
mentioned before last week you got to
speak to grace tame what an incredible
woman she
is incredible human being one of the
very sharp experiences that i i can
never forget
from being part of the australian of the
year awards a few years ago
was that when myself and 31 other people
sort of all collected in canberra
for the national announcement of who the
australians of the year would be
i remember going there and thinking i
can't believe i'm here
i can't believe that this is something i
get to take part in i was not thinking
at all about being
the recipient of the australia's local
hero award i was just so beyond
the pale of what i thought was possible
i was just focused on
these incredible individuals that i got
to meet and spend time with and be
inspired by
the thing that really shocked me that
has stuck with me ever since
is that to an individual every single
person i spoke to as we spent those few
days together
said almost exactly the same thing they
said i can't believe i'm here
i am just an ordinary person i'm just
doing i'm just doing my job or i did
what anyone would have done
under the same circumstances given the
same opportunity i had
and it sort of dawned on me we are all
ordinary people but ordinary people
nonetheless
are capable of extraordinary things and
so i guess
to inspire everyone who's watching right
now to think about the possibilities
you may feel like a very ordinary person
and so do i
and that's because we are but human
beings are all capable of incredible
things it's why i
love working with students all the time
every time i meet one i think wow
what are you capable of what are you
going to achieve and
how are you going to serve your
community and flourish in it
the possibilities they're endless so i
hope that's something which
i thought that inspires people tonight
wow those are three
fantastic takeaways eddie and we'll be
sure to put those up on our social media
channels
this chat will be up on the stay kind
youtube channel and i hope you'll share
it as well which i hope you will eddie
absolutely and ladies and gents and
girls and boys who joined this
conversation it's been such a delight
for
for eddie and me and don't forget we've
got another
kind july conversation next week with
catherine wolfgram who's a wonderful
transgender
advocate i hope you'll join us then and
really eddie i just want to say thank
you so much for giving us your time
and your wonderful experiences and words
on the subject of kindness and we wish
you all the best for going back to
school
thank you so much jane i really
appreciate it and hope everyone had a
great evening
bye